Hi, how are you doing?
My name is Elena Felice and I'm a content presenter for Epic Games.
It's nice meeting you.
So, in this course, we'll dive deep into worldbuilding for virtual production.
First, we will learn about the concept of derived data cache or DDC, understanding how it works
in Unreal Engine and in a real-time scenario.
Then, we will dive on a journey learning some basics of the engine,
spanning from lighting to assets editing using different tools like modeling,
procedural content generation, and blueprints.
We will also learn how to manage levels with the Stage Monitor and level snapshots.
We'll conclude with exploring some material and foliage basics,
together with checking out the engine profiling tool.
In the next video, we'll get an overview of our agenda for the upcoming lessons,
as well as learning about derived data cache.
Guess I'll see you there.
Alright, bye.